all right according to Wikipedia my
guests this week is either the former
king of Mesopotamia or youtuber not
afraid to speak his mind on
controversial topics that's right I have
Karl Benjamin better known as Sargon of
Akkad on the show Karl Sargon what do I
call you would I be once I get cold both
all day long so whichever one you will
come Sargon has sort of overtaken Karl
there's sort of a batman bruce wayne
situation here right you know that kind
of is actually yeah it's not the the
name Sargon has definitely um travelled
before me in many places where
progressives tend to congregate
progressives I'm shocked that you didn't
say regressives
but we'll get to that momentarily so
before we get into all the the deep
stuff and the topics and the meat of
this I want people to get to know you a
little bit because I think it's sort of
just recently that you're showing your
face more you're out there more your
name's getting out there a little bit
more so how did Karl Benjamin become
Sargon of Akkad oh that's an interesting
that's an interesting story it's not
actually that interesting it's all that
well it just make it interesting how
about that I'll try I'll try and I'll
try to fabricate something no basically
about about two and a half years ago I
you know when you're on the internet you
end up just choosing the moniker that
you sign in two places with and I just
happen to like the historical figure of
Sargon I can use an interesting figure I
like the sound of the name and you know
so I was just using that and I had
signed up to YouTube in 2010 just to
upload some videos of myself with an
ancient sling you know the sort of I you
know made one yeah I called historical
sort of documents and I tested it out
and it's that you can see why they were
dangerous weapons something and then a
few years later I was basically getting
ready already worried about the the sort
of political climate in the left I was
starting to see more and more often just
my own principles being completely
violated and it was really really really
worrying and it was a sort thing that
was genuinely starting to nor me because
I mean I would CP
all arguing for arguing against people's
freedom of speech or they would be
arguing against and the meritocratic
system or something like that and
everyone would seem to be going along
with it this this was you know there
were so many people going yeah that's
exactly how we should do things no panic
thinking Christ
I totally disagree I disagree on such a
fundamental level I have to say
something and so I found myself just a
motivated source right just like under
five minutes scripts or something and
then read them with a very very bad
microphone I mean it's all about the mic
it really is it's it's a it's a
magician's trick almost I had just the
cheapo microphone it was really really
terrible quality and I'd read these
ideas and they started gaining some
views of sort of people started
subscribe to my channel astir and
looking back now I'm thinking god they
were really there was a lot of
forbearance there about my technical
skills and what I was saying but I guess
some people agreed with what I was
saying because now I've got um just
possible quarter of a million
subscribers yeah yeah and now I do this
full-time and it's a it's a wonderful
thing to be doing is fighting for my
principles especially so I love that I
love that because as I say on the show
every week what I'm trying to do here is
make this about ideas and that's really
what you were talking about you were
hearing bad ideas and then you wanted to
beat them with better ideas and clearly
it's working because you got over
250,000 subscribers and and when I had
my personal awakening because everyone
knows at this point you know I've always
considered myself liberal then I was in
the progressive world which I now see as
some sort of mental disorder but when I
was having my awakening out of that
everyone online said to me you've got to
talk to Sargon so my so my first
question to you before we get into the
the heavy stuff is did you study
politics what brought you into the
political realm I didn't it was um it
was just watching my news I guess and
just watching you know popular I mean I
used to be I used to be a big fan of The
Young Turks I used to consider myself
progressive until I met progressives and
like I said I I couldn't believe the
things they were saying it it really
struck me as some sort of mental
disorder yeah
why would they start saying things like
this and yeah and then I then I I
thought I found myself sort of
floundering on my own because I you know
there's I'm not conservative I I can't I
can't bring myself to subscribe to
conservative ideas I think they don't
work with me I don't I don't believe in
them and so I was basically on my own
you know everyone I knew was who's a
liberal was quite happy to ignore the
foundational principles of liberalism in
order to in order to push progressivism
further and the more the more I've
learned about progressivism the more I
realize it's really used liberalism as a
Trojan horse to you know they've said
all we liberals with progressives and I
mean on the foot on the surface of it
they're not necessarily argue for
different things it's it's really the
methods that the problem it's not
necessarily the goals but yeah they
happily use the the terms
interchangeably and they are not
interchangeable at all yeah so let's
let's unpack that a little bit so I've
heard you say that you refer to yourself
as a classic liberal and the more that
I've been doing this I mean that's
really where I feel at home to I think
now I have some really strong
libertarian leanings also but there's
there's some there's some play there
there's some common ground there but
what does classic liberalism mean to you
um well it's just the it's just the
basic inline values that came out of the
alignment the civil liberties political
freedom freedom of expression freedom
Association economic freedom
representative democracy rules law it's
all these just there is no argument
against these ideas these are great
ideas they're universal ideas you know
everyone is protected under these ideas
unlike with progressivism where the
first thing they will do is demarcate a
group they will say right women black
people gay people these people need
special treatment and that special
treatment will involve the infringement
of your personal rights and that is
where I have a problem because if we all
ascribe to the same rights a we're being
treated as equals be nobody ends up
losing their rights and I don't have a
point see but I wish I did yeah that was
pretty good so this is sort of
an example of the road to hell is paved
with good intentions right because this
is where I've seen I know a lot of
progressives a lot of them won't talk to
me anymore people that I met were my
good friends only you know six eight
months ago that won't talk to me anymore
but I believe that for the most part and
we're gonna get into some of the really
dangerous ones but I think for the most
part people that consider themselves
progressive most of the people that are
going to Bernie Sanders rallies I think
of good people I think their intentions
are current so we're really talking
about the methodology here right yeah
but there are a few the problem is you
have a bunch of you know a bunch of
motivating factors that can't coalesce
and in mixed in with that you have the
more sort of pernicious aspects of
people who can see where this is going
because a lot of it involves giving the
benefit of the doubt to people who you
would otherwise necessarily be skeptical
to people making I mean for example rape
laws one of the big progressive pushes
and it is is to have it certainly victim
quote-unquote the the alleged victim is
believed and therefore the burden of
proof becomes laid on the person who's
being accused rather than on the accuser
and they do this by the use of
statistics they say oh well you know I
come up with the number is but something
like I know 5% of accused rapists go to
jail or something like that and then
therefore they assume that there is a
massive problem with the system that 95%
of accused rapists are also actual
rapist and therefore just being let off
through about system but the thing is a
we don't know we have no idea how many
of the people who are accused are
actually legitimate rapists and deserve
to be condemned for it and convicted for
but secondly what we're doing there is
reversing the system because at the
moment what we have is a system that
isn't perfect but can deliver justice in
a reliable way
you know that we can be quite sure that
the people going to jail probably aren't
innocent you know we've been through a
rigorous rigorous trial the burden of
proof is on the accuser they've managed
to prove beyond reasonable doubt and you
know that's fine because that way you're
going to get the minimum number of
people who didn't do anything wrong
being punished as if they did some
wrong whereas to flip the script on that
would mean that you now have a system
that is inherently unjust that might be
able to deliver justice on occasion the
occasion being the person being accused
is on camera somewhere else at the time
that they're supposed to have been doing
the rape or something like that you know
right it's it's that sort of thing it's
it would be incidental justice you know
you couldn't rely on it because you
don't presume the innocence of the
people being accused the guilt is being
presumed and it's being done like say
how good motives the idea that you know
we don't want to call the victims Liars
and say no I I don't want to call the
victim a liar either but it's one of
those points where you're on the horns
of a dilemma and you have no choice but
to take a responsible course of action
for the safety of someone who hasn't
done anything wrong right so all right
so there's a lot there that I wanna I
knew that that's how this conversation
was gonna go because there's so much to
talk about and then these things are
always inextricably linked that's what I
found
whenever I'm talking about anything
related to sort of regressive ideology
and then when you start talking about
feminism and Islamism and all these
things they're they're also in extra
inextricably linked so let's let's jump
into gamergate for a second and then
we'll get back to some of that stuff
because gamergate I think is one of the
things that really sort of put you on
the map and even by saying the word
gamergate I've made people crazy we know
this now I've discussed it with a couple
people I've had Milo you're not listen
I've talked about it with Christina Hoff
Sommers but you yourself you are a true
gamer correct yes I am indeed a true
gamer
what do you play in these days I play a
game called Ark survival evolved most
actually have my own server where I pay
for a server where I get to run around
killing virtual dinosaurs it's great Wow
well thank you for taking a moment from
slaying dinosaurs to to join me here but
yeah you've really been in the gamergate
thing and I think are considered sort of
an expert on it so can you give me like
a 2-3 minute explanation of what
gamergate is and I know that's almost
impossible because it seems like it's
something different to everybody it is I
can give you my version of what it is
but like I say it is that
to everybody and you're gonna get people
who are gonna say that's not what
gamergate isn't not so for me it is it's
a very definite reaction to regressives
infiltrating the video game media now
this is something that we saw we saw
happening over the course about five
years where they were just increment it
just larger and larger numbers of them
would be hired at various gaming
publications and then they would start
writing articles like are these video
games sexist why are these video games
misogynist there are no trans people in
these video games this is racist this is
you know the kind of regressive lines
yeah 101 yeah and they would be
promoting very famous feminists like
Anita sarkeesian or Zoe Quinn people
with and I don't I don't want I mean but
very few real credentials in the video
game industry mean like zoe quinn want
the the franz ferdinand of gamergate she
made a a free digital did you ever have
those choose her own adventure books I
love choose-your-own-adventure
I probably had everyone right yeah yeah
basically that's what she had made she
had made a digital chooser an adventure
book it was all all text no no nothing
else in it it can't take him very long
but it was about learning to deal with
depression and I might never had the
prescience so I can't judge the game on
that merits on that I'm sure it's very
good but your average gamer this wasn't
really a game there wasn't a failed
state you know wasn't there wasn't
really antiquing play was more like an
interactive novel which is again it's in
itself is fine but the gaming press
because she was a prominent feminist and
regressive she got unbelievable amounts
of coverage and I mean when I say
unbelievers mean any amount of coverage
for the app is more than you would
expect and so people can they were
getting sick of the agenda being pushed
on them and it's the same of the need
sarkeesian
when Anita sarkeesian did her
Kickstarter it was everywhere everyone
knew about it and yes everyone also knew
that the arguments she was presenting
were half-truths they were cherry-pick
they were she was finding individual
examples that didn't really represent
the gaming industry or any even you know
sub sections of the gaming industry and
presenting them as if they were a
categoric statement on the condition
of the entire gaming industry and so
everyone was really color annoyed by
this point especially as the way that
these people work is by rolling up your
emotions so almost everything they say
is fundamentally accusatory they would
say things like you're a sexist you're a
racist if you like these games there
aren't enough you know black people in
this game right enough women in this
game gay people all the sort of thing
and if you're enjoying it you're a bad
person whereas most popular people
thinking well just hell just just make
the games you want to make right but
that's not what these people are
interested in whatsoever and so got to
the point where Zoe Quinn was caught
having an affair with her boss who is
involved in video games and also a
journalist called Nathan Grayson and the
video game industry's press has always
been corrupt and you know it's always
been carbons come out of a hobby press
it's always been really really bad but
this when you say corrupt just to pause
for one sec will you say corrupt I mean
things like you know people paying off
the magazine writers so that they'd get
better reviews on the game so they'd
sell more games I mean real corrupt
stuff yeah yeah your face as well so you
go to a video game sort of online
magazine and that the backdrop would be
the advertisement for a game that then
would be reviewed in the center column
you know it's sure it's not you know
it's not even then I'm trying to hide it
but for the most part nobody really
cared because they weren't being preachy
about you know they were trying to sell
me video games and that's what people
were their thoughts and therefore nobody
was any that bothered but then the
regressives turned up and started being
corrupt in a whole different way instead
of instead of being my flowed by money
which I suppose is to their credit they
were motivated by ideology and so now
they would hire people into positions
and promote things that were all based
on cronyism it was all their friends and
family members of Monarch they would
they would push everything to do with
their agenda and people realistically
people have just been really really sick
convinced but they were tired of this
phone moralism tired of being told that
they were bad people even though you
know obviously none of these people are
actually bad people you know nobody
knows who all of these people are and
yeah they're being they're being pre
judged before anything happens and it
got to the point where people like no
enough you know this has got to stop
and that's what what
basically it was called the quince
piracies salad and then the video game
press instead of turning around and
saying something like okay fair enough
we haven't been doing our due diligence
you know we a lot of them are
professional trained journalists like
Steven that's a tiller from kotaku his
master's degree in journalism and he's
there saying well do we have to be
objective what's the need for objective
journalism and so you can instantly see
the problems that were inherent in the
video game industry yeah and I know we
can we can really go down the rabbit
hole yeah we could spend three hours
with this but I think that's I think
that's a nice little beginning piece of
it but what I really find fascinating
about it and why I've brought it up
several times is because the same things
that you're talking about how the
regressive sort of infiltrated this and
turned something that had nothing to do
with sexism or racism or any of these
things they made it about that and I
think when I was on your show I was
saying how I you know I used to be a
huge gamer I'm not that much anymore but
I like the community and I do play some
games here and there but like you know I
played Grand Theft Auto and yeah you
could steal a car and punch a hooker and
people would say well that's against
women but you could also punch a man so
should they only have it that you'd only
punch men I mean even the logic behind
it doesn't really stand to critique and
there's no winning either and so this is
the point is that it's all what was
called a katka trap it's either you are
this thing or you're this thing you
don't even realize it you know and
there's no falsifiability to any of
their hypotheses but the main problem if
you think about they look like with
grand theft auto so what the options not
include women in the game no way they'd
they freak out if you couldn't put women
in the game right or you can have the
women not being able to be treated like
men again they'd be freaking out that's
not equal that's all so what I mean what
are you gonna have you're gonna have
women so that they just can't be damaged
or you know you they will not allow you
to treat women like men you know you
can't beat up women you can't but you
can beat up men and so you're at you're
in this position whether you've got no
win you know there's no good answer and
that's how they want it they want you
dancing to their tune yeah and that's
what that's what's so fascinating about
this and why I think it's so related to
the political situation with the
regressives and I also think that's why
gamergate blew up the way it did because
gamers generally
are gonna skew a little younger than the
people that are solely interested in
politics so because of that I think it
was this group of people who had never
been used to being attacked or silenced
before and they were young and they were
online and they were ready to coalesce
around something and I think that's what
made it so so magical or something you
know jaemin's game has actually long
been the demon in the in the bedroom
no no felt like the American Christians
in the late 90s early 2000s there was
Clinton and Joe Lieberman actually
brought legislation to try and try and
sort sensor video games so this is
another reason I would never vote for
Hillary I mean I don't think anyone ever
should she's a corporate shill don't
vote fail Larry yeah I mean there are so
many reasons Nazi basically really can
get into that - yeah gamers are actually
quite familiar with being attacked
politically because of their hobby even
though there hasn't been a single study
that's ever really conclusively proven
anything about video games in fact there
are dozens that say well there's no
connection between video games and
anything you know and if you look at the
statistics the rise of video games has
coincided with the descent of violence
so I mean I'm not saying they're
connected but it's one of those things
that there is literally nothing to show
that video games are doing anything
wrong in fact there's quite a lot so
they're doing a lot of things well I
remember that I think maybe it was
around 91 or 92 when joe lieberman was
leading that that fight against video
games I think it was because of MORTAL
KOMBAT I was playing it on Sega Genesis
at the time and I would come home from
school and play that for hours with my
friends I never ripped anyone skull out
with their spine attached to it you know
any man
not once now I tried once but I yeah I
never successfully did it so that says
something actually I think you can prove
that it probably helps people in a more
healthy way than some of their anger and
frustration don't you think I think then
multiplayer games all day you know they
get they get groups of guys to hang out
and do something that's not dangerous or
violent you know and think about I mean
when I was a kid if we weren't playing
video games we were on the streets you
know right it was better for us to be at
home playing video games than to not be
playing video games so I I honestly
can't see where the objections come from
you know but it wasn't
the same with anything like Dungeons and
Dragons in the 80s on music in the 70s
you know video games the 90s and the
2000s there is always something that the
you know poll clutching moral majority
or so they would like to position
themselves as has got to rail against
something and ironically that was always
the religious right you know that was
always the highly religious
authoritarian right now it is the highly
regressive authoritarian laugh yeah and
this is the horse-shoe theory that we
talk about all the time that the
extremes on both sides come together all
right so last thought on gamergate you
know the other thing that i think is
really nice about the community is that
people who are gamers it doesn't matter
what race you are it doesn't matter what
religion you are what sex or sexuality
any of the little dividing boxes that
the left wants to put us in it doesn't
matter what you are and that's why the
community is so strong so then when when
these people that are writing these
articles say well gamers are sexist or
gamers are racist it actually it
literally has no meaning because it's as
diverse a community as you could
possibly put out there right yeah I mean
it you literally can't tell by playing a
video game what race or gender the
people you're playing with are because
everyone gets to choose their own avatar
they get to customize their name you
know the only way you'd know is by voice
chat you know so for the vast majority
of people playing video games is not
tied to identity politics and the you
know it's interesting is the regressive
academics actually did they spent a lot
of time sort of planning their assault
on video games and they spent a lot of
time doing research and there was an
academic a feminist academic called
Adrian Shaw who did a series of studies
not based on particularly large sample
sizes but large enough I would say to at
least give you the impression that
they're going the wrong direction
because her conclusions and she was
someone looking for a way to sort of you
know crack open the video game industry
with a good reason to attack it she
found that basically video games didn't
need diversity video games had diversity
class meant that's you know that and
that in itself where does a regressive
begin they're a plan of attack
you know if they think they're attacking
is already diverse you know and so
basically it
led to her reframing the study she had
already conducted in a different way in
the the language is very opaque but um
basically she was not happy that there
was a plurality of markets and now I
personally think a plurality of markets
is a wonderful thing
I think Lina if you want a video if you
want video games about under Japanese
hentai great that's your business I'm
not interested in that
I won't I want video games about killing
dinosaurs that's great that's my niche
yeah everyone gets their own niche you
know whereas the problem that they have
is that they wanted hegemony over they
didn't want a plurality of markets
because then you could have diverse
market market antennas they wanted every
market to be controlled effectively by
their ideology and thankfully it's not
gonna happen right so just to be clear
about that so there are people that are
probably playing Mario Kart that have
nothing to do with the people that are
playing the games you're playing so it
doesn't make sense even to lump all
those people together absolutely I mean
inna there will obviously be some
crossover in every every game genre but
by and large you get people who have
different preferences and they play
different things it's like um one of the
things that were saying one of the
things they the big family platters are
almost half of people playing video
games or women's okay great the one are
they playing they're not playing call of
duty you know they're not set they're on
their Xboxes but their headphones in
running around calling each other gay
you know they're playing candy crush and
farm Valen which all perfectly valid
forms of entertainment and more power to
them I want them to play the games they
want to play but these you know by this
fact they it doesn't justify changing
anything about the games I play because
of the games they play and vice versa is
true I don't want their games being
changed to suit me either you know that
would be the last thing I would want to
impose on and so this is basically one
of the things that regressive left will
always do is use statistics in the most
slippery way possible
you know lies damned lies and statistics
really does apply it you I mean they
they will use statistics to justify
anything so be be careful about the use
of statistics with the regressive left
[Music]